Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conner. Today's episode with Daniel Morgan is going to be delightful
because she's going to talk about a great product that I personally take myself. It's a cvd product
that is special because it's different than other cvd products. Everything that I want in a cvd product
and Torage hats. That's what Daniel's going to be talking about today. This is personal experience that
she's dealt with and hundreds of people that she's worked with with interage cvd product. You're
going to love this and this is going to be a great episode. And as always, if you like this, make
sure you click the like button. Share it on Facebook. We really appreciate that. If you're on YouTube,
make sure you subscribe and hit that little alarm notification button so you don't miss any of our
further episodes. Thanks. Let's jump right in with Daniel. Hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner's
another episode of our podcast show and today we have a very special guest, kind of semi-related to me,
right? You are married to my cousin and for those who don't understand our family, I think I have
88 first cousins and my mother's side, 88 first cousins. If anybody meets that, then you win a cookie
for the day. But it's exciting. I just got to know you, Daniel, just a few years ago,
and got to know the products that you're involved with that were using those. A lot of our
office, I want you to kind of share your story, tell us who you are. All right. Well, thank you for
having me. It's a pleasure to be here. So my name's Daniel Morgan and I grew up in Northern Minnesota,
some from a small town and I was an athlete and so I was very active and I thought I was healthy. But
I remember getting into my late teenage years and really, really struggling with energy and cravings.
And so that carried on into college. I went to college for dental hygiene. I've always been
intrigued by health and wellness and in the human body and decided to kind of specialize and
went into dental hygiene. But throughout college, my energy got even worse. It really bothered me.
And so I kind of went on this quest and this search for, how do I get my health back? I started
teaching yoga. I started doing some other things entrepreneurial and then eventually found more
of a holistic health coaching path for myself. And in the meantime, I had met Brian, my husband,
and he, you know, had a lot of physical injuries. He's a blue collar guy. He's worked extremely hard
his whole life. So his back was shot. His knees are shot. And he's kind of been an experiment for me
over the last 10 years of us being together, but helping him rehab his health. You know, a lot of
people would come to me and say, okay, what do I do for this or what do I do for that? And then I found
an integrative health coaching online school. And so that's kind of where I found my
my education, the platform that was right for me. And so that's kind of where I settled was,
you know, doing some health coaching with people, working on, you know, just different
health habits and trying to simplify health for people because it can be very complicated. And
that can be stressful in itself when someone's trying to, you know, get healthy and change up their
diet and things. And then using the evolved health products over the years has just been,
has been really awesome for our entire family. So I had been following hemp oil, CBD oil for a
couple of years just behind the scenes, some of the some of the experts, some of the gurus that I
follow had been have been talking about it for a long time. But I just wasn't sure, you know,
what company to try it from or, you know, what, what type to try. So there's many different,
different types of oil out there. And then our CEO decided that once the farm bill passed in
December, that he wanted to create a product because he's been over the last 20 years, he's been
involved in many different patented products on the market and is a very intelligent man. And so
he created a product for evolved called entourage, which is a broad spectrum hemp oil. So broad
spectrum means that it includes more than just the CBD cannabinoid or molecule. And but they pull
out the THC. So we're very excited about that, you know, just just getting educated on it's like kind
of a whole new world of what this nourishment can do for the body for human health. And we've had it
now on the market through evolve for about seven months now. And it's just been very fascinating to
see, you know, how one form of nourishment has such a big influence on so many different body
systems, organs, you know, just balance and health and well-being. And so that product has been awesome.
What we've seen over the last seven months, and I know we're just scratching the tip of the iceberg
as, you know, people continue to take it. Their body's going to continue to do some amazing things. But,
you know, for for discomfort, a lot of people are in discomfort, right? They've got injuries,
they've been in car accidents, you know, they suffer with joint issues or whatever it may be. But what
we found is combining that product with the limitless for people that are in excruciating discomfort
or just really want to attack inflammation from different angles. That's been very, very powerful.
We've seen for people who are struggling with anxiety, depression, anything that has to do with mood.
It's been very powerful for that. My son, so I give my son about, I had probably about eight drops
in the evening before bed. And sometimes I'll give him a couple drops in the morning, if you can.
And he's how old are you? He's four. Okay. So he's four. So he has, he's got some
gut health issues that we've been working on since he was born. And some leaky gut. And so we've
been, you know, doing a lot to try to really heal that and get his digestion back to normal.
And of course, that relates to unhealthy skin. So he's had, you know, some skin issues just,
you know, rashes and sometimes he'll, it's pretty much under control. But you can just, I could tell
the integrity of his skin wasn't as healthy as it should be. Well, when I started giving him
entourage in just a week, I could tell his skin was so much smoother. And, and it's been able to
control, you know, if he needs something, he shouldn't eat, which he's four. So it's very, I can't
control his diet 24 seven, but he does a pretty good job for being four. But if he eats, you know,
a little bit too much gluten or dairy, he might get some rashes on the back of his arms or on his legs.
And so I've noticed just with helping him with the hemp oil, that that's really, really
improved his digestion. And I can see it's working on his immune system as well because now we're back
to preschool and all the kids, you know, you walk in that room and it is just, there's runny
noses and sneezing and coughing everywhere. So that's been, it's been a really exciting product to
work with Dr. Kevin. And now there's so much research, you know, literally on a daily basis on
CBD oil and the benefits because your, your cells have those cannabinoid receptors that do different
things depending on what cell it is. And it can help heal the gut. It can help decrease inflammation
especially in the brain. It can help balance their own transmitters so that can have all those
mood benefits. And that's how originally most of the research, you know, several years ago,
that's what it was really push for because they noticed such a difference in people with seizures
being balanced by CBD. And so what in the world is going on here? We've used these medications
on these people with, with little help and they go on a CBD product and they don't have any seizures
anymore. So, but we see it with cancer. There's more and more research coming up with cancer and
all so many of our patients are on that product. So, though it decreases chronic inflammation,
it can stimulate the immune system, which those are kind of two opposing forces in the body normally.
So if you take something to decrease the medication, decrease chronic inflammation, it shuts down
your immune response. And that's now what we want to do. That's what you typically see with steroids
for a CBD. It can decrease chronic inflammation and stimulate the immune response, which is just
almost miraculous. So, it's just really exciting. Tell me what makes a garage different. We,
be careful, say it better, but different than some other products that are on the market.
Yes. So, you know, if people have been following CBD or if you're brand new to kind of looking
into it and educating yourself, there's quite a wide variety of different options out there. So,
what makes us unique and different is number one, we blend the aloe vera molecule ACE manin in with
our oil. So, you're getting two very powerful nutrients. You're getting the hemp,
you're getting the aloe, and that then combining that in, you know, in entourage.
I have a several blog posts on what Daniel's talking about there with the ACE manin.
It's not the same as just taking aloe. So, it's the very specific polysaccharides that are in the
ACE manin that make it very different. So, look at those blog posts, because that's a huge piece
of immune stimulation extra beyond this, just the CBD that the entourage has, because it has the
immune of all the immune product ACE manin in the CBD as well. So, sorry, I'll let you continue there.
No, that's okay. The second thing is when you process CBD or a full spectrum of broad spectrum
hemp oil, a lot of the natural terpenes, which are plant essences is what get terpenes or what
get plants they're smell. The terpenes get lost in the processing, even if you're using a very,
you know, low heat, high quality processing technique, the terpenes help the nourishment
activate those receptor sites more effectively. So, the terpenes can get lost. So, we add back in
terpenes from the hemp plant. So, we put that back into the oil so that you're maximizing your,
well, not only your money, but you're maximizing the impact of the cannabinoids on
your endocannabinoid system or those receptor sites. So, that's another thing that makes it unique.
There are other companies that do that, but just just the fact that we have that, you know,
terpened blend does help the nourishment work better. But the last thing in which I think is really
exciting is there's a new technology to help absorption. So, because the cannabinoids are a fat
molecule and they're very large. And so, when you take a CBD or a full spectrum or broad spectrum
hemp oil, those molecules have a hard time getting into the bloodstream because they're so large.
So, if you put it under your tongue, if you use it sublingually and you hold it there, very,
it's a very small percentage. They're saying between anywhere from 4% to about 20% of those molecules
are actually going to get into the bloodstream through the skin and under our tongue.
So, that's a very low absorption rate and the hemp needs to get into the blood in order to
activate the endocannabinoid system. So, we have some cutting edge technology that not only breaks down
the particle size of those, you know, large molecules, but it also creates a water compatible
product. So, if you look at our oil, it's not oil, it's more of a watery substance. And so,
that brings the absorption rate to 90%. So, your average oil, if you grab a hemp oil off the shelf
or a CBD isolate, and it's suspended in coconut oil, MCT oil, or, you know, some sort of oil,
which is typically what they do, your absorption rate is going to be on average about 10%.
So, that means 90% of that nourishment is passing through your system
and your body's not able to utilize it. So, if you get a 50 milligram supplement of CBD oil,
which can be very pricey, you might only be getting 5 milligrams CBD. And this is where I hear
a lot of people, I tried CBD and it didn't work. Many times, it's they're trying a CBD product that
might be like 8 milligrams and they're only getting, you know, 10% of that. It's just not going to have
any effect on the body. So, that makes entourage a very unique product, pushing up the cost more
cost effective. And if you really look at the cost of products out there, it, by itself,
isn't any more expensive. Matter of fact, it's going to be cheaper than many of the other CBD
products out there. And you're really getting, you know, 90% absorption rate versus 10 to 15%.
Yeah. So, you take the aloe, you take the added turpine blend, you take the water compatible technology,
and that product was awarded a global award at Cana, Mexico in back in April. So, it's very
cutting edge technology. Not many people know about water compatible yet, but talking about cost.
So, our two ounce bottle, you're paying about nine cents per usable milligram.
That's how much value you're getting, whereas most products you're going to pay 30 to 50 cents per
use of a gram. Big difference. Big difference. Yeah. Yeah, great product. We've been excited about it.
That's another product I personally take. So, we have a lot of patients taking that product more,
so than anyone that we have probably. And it's just been proven to be so effective for cancer
patients as well. So, thanks so much for all you do. Yeah, thank you for having me. Thank you again. Bye-bye.